de dollars à une entreprise,
comme nous le raconte
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
♪ J'ai le goût ♪
♪ À la Place Versailles ♪
♪ De m'y promener ♪
♪ Chez Club Piscine
on joue dans l'eau ♪
♪ Da Giovanni ♪
- Quelques notes suffisent
pour qu'on les reconnaisse,
qu'on les associe à une marque
et qu'on les ait en tête
pour toute la journée.
♪ Le Clan Panneton
pour déménager ♪
PIERRE-OLIVIER CYR, proprio.,
Déménagement le Clan Panneton
- Un bon jingle de pub,
ça peut changer le destin
d'une entreprise. L'entreprise,
en 93, était en faillite,
pratiquement. Mon père a acheté
l'entreprise pour une poignée
de change.
♪ Le 937-0707 ♪
- La stratégie de relance
pour le Clan Panneton : marteler
un numéro de téléphone simple
à retenir. Mais ils ont dû
convaincre l'agence
de marketing.
- Leur réaction a été la
suivante : "M. Cyr, vous allez
faire le pire flop publicitaire
au Québec". Encore aujourd'hui,
lorsque mes camions et mes
chauffeurs se promènent partout
au Québec, à chaque jour,
mes chauffeurs entendent des
gens leur chanter la fameuse
chanson du Clan Panneton.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Des musiques de pub,
Jessie Gnaedinger en a
composé des centaines.
JESSE GNAEDINGER, compositeur
- Il y a souvent beaucoup
de contraintes. Tu peux pas
tout le temps faire ce que
tu envisages comme musique
pour un spot, parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde qui vont
décider, c'est comme plus
un travail d'équipe.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Des mélodies qui nous restent
en tête et c'est là tout
l'objectif.
♪ Tu devrais aller
chez Jean Coutu ♪
JEAN-JACQUES STRÉLISKI, prof.
ass., Département de marketing
- C'est le principe du ver
d'oreille, hein! Il faut
laisser dans la mémoire
des gens des noms, des marques,
des ritournelles, exactement
comme le fait la chanson.
♪ Sico, Sico par-ci ♪
♪ Sico, Sico par-là ♪
♪ On donne tous un petit coup
de Sico par-ci par-là ♪
- Les ritournelles publicitaires
sont apparues dès l'invention
de la radio commerciale
et leur popularité ne s'est
jamais démentie.
♪ Sico, Sico ♪
♪ Qu'est-ce qui fait donc
chanter les p'tits Simard ♪
♪ C'est les p'tits puddings
Laura Secord ♪
- Qu'elles soient détournées
par des humoristes...
♪ Quel endroit, quel festin
et toute une ambiance ♪
... ou reprises par artistes
connus...
♪ Barbie's ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
... elles finissent par faire
partie de la culture populaire.
- Quand on réussit ça, c'est
vraiment une grosse victoire.
Ça milite pour le capital
sympathie des marques.
(coups de klaxon)
- Des vers d'oreille,
pour nous convaincre de croquer
dans la pomme... On a beau
connaître la chanson,
mais ça fonctionne encore.
- Ah, ah! Familiprix!
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada,